-Our next guest is
an Emmy-Award winning acto
you know from his iconic rol
as The Fonz on "Happy Days,"
as well as shows like "Arreste
Development" and "Barry."
He stars in "Monsters at Work,
with new episodes streamin
Wednesdays on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-Yes, I know bowlers!
They don't call me
"No Splits Fritz" for nothing.
-They -- They call you that?
-For nothing.
-Huh! I never heard them
call you that.
-Well, they do,
they do, they do.
And we've got Pin Pal Val
over there and No Gutter Cutter.
Hmm. Duncan doesn't play,
but he loves the snachos!
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Henry Winkler.
Hello, Henry!
-How are you?
-Good. You can --
You're not here.
You can take your mask off
Henry.
-Oh, right, right. Okay.
You know what?
There's a mandate now -- we have
to wear it inside in L.A.
-Oh, no!
See, this is what happens when
not everyone gets vaccinated
You got to wear it
in your own home.
-Yeah. You know what?
It is shocking, but here we are.
You know, I was alive
when polio struck America,
and I didn't hear
one person say,
"You know, I don't think
I'm gonna take the vaccine."
-That was a different --
It was a different time.
It was a simpler time.
-Yes. And no more polio.
-There we go.
You haven't heard
hide nor hair of polio
for a great time.
You know what?
I'm very happy to see this
Because you have actually
given them to me,
so I know exactly
what I'm looking at.
You are an accomplished
children's book author,
and you have some
right behind you.
-I do.
-And this is no joke.
You've written -- Is it
over 30 books at this point?
-Yes, yes, 37 novels
with my partner, Lin.
Uh, for -- Starting
in the second grade --
Well, first grade, second grade,
and all the way to sixth grade
And look what else
I have sitting on my books
Because -- Congratulations
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you have
just made Amber's day,
not that anybody needs
to make her day.
She's the happiest person
I know.
-She is --
and uses the word "what"
better than anybody
I've ever met.
-Yeah.
She should teach just "what" -
a "what" class at Juilliard.
-I'll tell ya --
And it's difficult
because, you know, I try -
When she's not around,
I try very hard
to steal the use of "what,
and I should just
leave it alone.
-Well, it is lovely,
I will say --
It's lovely to hear your voice
in an animated show like this.
And I'm wondering --
I know you have five
grandchildren, and obviously -
-One on the way.
-One on the way, as well!
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Now, I'm assuming
they're not too engaged
with your work like "Barry,"
but do they enjoy
the new monster show?
-You know what? They do,
but I did force them.
-Okay.
-I do --
No, I have soldered the remote
to Disney+ just for that.
But it is so much fun
because people love --
of all ages --
love "Monsters, Inc."
And the "Monsters at Work"
takes place right after
the movie's finish.
And Billy Crystal is in it
John Goodman is in it.
Ben Feldman is in it.
Mindy is in it.
It's just great.
-Now, what about "Happy Days"?
This is a show
I grew up with as a kid.
Has that sort of
permeated its way
into your grandkids'
viewing habits at all?
-Two years ago,
my oldest grandson, Ace,
I showed up at his house
because I --
I like to be there
when they're trick-or-treating
I sit on their doorstep
and hand out candy
to all the children
that come with them.
And he was dressed as The Fonz
He had on the pleather --
Whatever it's called.
The fake leather.
He had on the jeans.
His red hair was slicked back.
My heart fell out of my body
[ Laughter ]
-Did you say his name was Ace?
Because that's the rare case
of someone with a name
that's cooler than The Fonz.
-He is.
He just won his championship
baseball game.
-Great.
-First pitch, first hit
of the season, home run.
And they went on
to win the championship.
Oh, my God.
And then I made them
those books, you know --
snap fly, a chat fly.
You know what I'm talking about?
-I love when I'm so confiden
it's not a paid endorsement.
-Yeah, well, it isn't,
because I -- I had to pay.
I got, you know --
But I made them those books.
And Jules, his younger brother
also had his first
baseball season.
-That's fantastic. I'm gla
that things are going so wel
for the entire Winkler clan.
I have more questions.
We're going to be right back
with more from our friend
Henry Winkler.